welcome to this video playing milk
palomo pillar here that's a cool name
and so I am from South Africa maybe
really from the other no South Africa
has some ims not many I think two or two
or three maybe maybe a couple more I
don't know so let's see it's a sideline
here on of the ratty gambit I tend to
confuse move odyssey I have to admit
that I came taking a bit there okay
night takes me so he's giving me a good
Center okay and yeah off for simply kick
it for about simplifications ok let's
try to pressure rice b7 a bit Ruby one
yeah it's probably quite nice the bishop
is good 1g two and i have some pressure
on the be fun so loopy one is definitely
not on so i have to do this first then
Ruby one next
maybe if file is a movie em let's do
that the question is route 88 look p8
Queen a form is a is a problem for him
rupay 8 Queen Queen f4 threatens your
chick b7 actually funny little tactic
hmm b6 Queen a for loop c8 and my Pig
might be okay yeah that might be okay
doesn't look great but shouldn't be a
huge issue okay it's going for that if I
go Queen a four I mean sb5 yeah there's
be five maybe b5 is actually the move
okay let's do this first and check then
so a for I guess so that should be
should be decent anyway so chicks chicks
okay let's cancel without connected
roofs I cannot play this position anyway
so back here trying for for invasion
their route a six and stick and now look
to a 6 or look to a seven I wonder
what's better um yeah okay six andrew k
one that looks good now I'm threatening
rook a seven oops nada isn't that
winning a piece here
odyssey cavity seven gasps he isn't nope
so it's a this is a full it's a queen
fall queen for 40 km check okay let's
see what about will Quinn be too does he
have to retreat with the rock well
pretty much can go up to one
I can also go kingi to hear I wonder
maybe this is an this is easier Bishop
see one was my idea yeah maybe do that
this probably looks a bit passive but I
want to get the rug out queen bee
towards the next move
should page 3 of Quincy one so it's
really just continuing this okay
I don't know it feels a bit pointless to
be honest check check now coming to d6
now
black resigns yeah so that I had a nice
position out of the elbows out of the
opening nothing great but it was closed
quite comfortable like this d 3 a 5
rupee one rupee eight yeah I don't know
one idea is an interesting is ideas this
if you know goes like a six I can take
here and just win the window game
immediately but b5 is coming and then it
doesn't seem so clear if my queen is
good on a four so I went with that
because well I suspected that he would
go b5 b6 is better i think it's just far
more solid here here for a six castles
here and white is a bit better rook a
one yeah J Teague's rook a seven was
possible but that was not a bad move MC
ade and here yeah why does a bit better
due to rook 87 I'm just controlling the
only open file but okay this is just
blunders I think I Queenie 80 so a it's
got Queenie idea by droopy seven Daniel
Queenie eight is not very very nice but
but playable of course this just own
yeah wins the peace or all the Queen for
look so this was a yeah pretty pretty
clean when it seemed okay thanks for
watching